in this short essay existence in human
freedom Gabrielle Marcel is criticizing
the existentialist philosophy of
jean-paul Sartre that's what the bulk of
this this text is actually focused on
it's a critical examination not merely a
bashing but an exploration of where
Sartre is getting things right and where
Sartre is getting things wrong in
Marcel's view yeah and in a certain way
it's sort of like a a return shot across
the bow because Sartre had criticized
Marcel explicitly as a Christian
existentialist counter poising himself
in his own view against that of Marcel
in existentialism is a humanist and he
sort of singled him out as a
representative of Christian existential
ISM and Marcel is going to point out
things where Sartre is making
assumptions or making choices that he
doesn't need to make and thereby ending
up drawing mistaken conclusions and he
wants to try to sift out what he thinks
is really legitimate and valuable
inserts work from what he thinks is more
fortuitous more polemical less grounded
and in some cases actually quite
mistaken so there's a few things I want
to say in this this beginning this
introduction to this one of these has to
do with this schema that I've got over
here Marcel is saying that if we
consider sart's work as a whole and he's
not considering sart's work as something
totally detached from his personality or
his life that he is an existentialist we
can we can say that Sartre begins from
certain starting points and I hesitate
to call these premises but if you want
you can call these premises in a very
broad sense beginning points in the
classic term are K you know principles
as we would translate them many of these
are actually experiences fundamental
experiences some of which Marcel is
going to say I think these are actually
quite valid and Sartre is going to have
a
mix of let's just use you know good and
they add not necessarily a moral sense
but in the sense of being well-founded
in the sense of actually being
applicable to other people rather than
just a jean-paul Sartre in its own
particular way of viewing things and
what's going to happen is through
thinking about these things through
through ruminating on them and gradually
forming a system around them and
carrying out some processes of inference
and argumentation Sartre is going to end
up coming up with some conclusions there
are some very important you know
principles that are that have the role
of conclusion and then are also premises
for further things in existentialism
like man is condemned to be free that
lapidary statement that would be an
example of something that started
arguing for on the basis of some other
things and then of course it functions
you know in his philosophy as a premise
for for other inferences but it's also
something that's a conclusion and what
Marcel wants to do is to say we're start
has actually gotten things right he's
he's really right he's dead on he and
generally that's going to be a product
of having started off from some things
that aren't actually true with good
valuable but that sort mixes in quite a
few other things assumptions that he
didn't need to make he and he's gonna
end up in some things that we actually
want to say no he's wrong about that we
want to reject those and the way in
which we're going to do that is in part
by sort of tracing our way back to the
starting points that were mistaken that
were over-hasty that were the product of
careless thinking or the wrong point of
view or a lack of openness to things so
that's one thing I want to point out I
have a list here the basically
six different sets of topics that Marcel
goes through they're not divided up by
you know section or anything like that
lettering but I think you can divide
them out into these he begins by talking
about the nature of existence for Sartre
he dwells on the function of social
order or family as a particular instance
of it we could put the bourgeoisie in
there as well
Sartre is very down on all that he looks
at sart's notion of being for self and
of bad faith then he talked about
alterity meaning others other people the
possibility of communion or community he
talked about starts a discussion of the
gaze and then he talks about Hell being
other people you talks about starts
notion of freedom and the fact that for
Sartre were condemned to be free and
then he criticizes start for a lack of
attention to what receptivity involves
and the finally he takes on sart's
atheism and sort of a postulate and
talks about Sartre as being a villa fire
of freedom in the process which is
really quite an interesting thing to say
now that's where we're going in just a
few moments but I actually want to begin
by bringing up a few things from the
very end of this work that I think are
very helpful for putting it into context
on a first reading particularly if you
not you know that familiar with Marcel's
work or with Sarris work so Marcel
here's one of the things he says
existentialism stands today at a parting
of the ways it is in the last analysis
obliged either to deny or to transcend
itself it denies itself quite simply
when it falls to the level of infantile
ektachrome aterial ISM which is what
Sark's is is doing or Marcel's
criticism here would apply as well to de
Beauvoir to Camus perhaps to Heidegger
that that would be a sort of debated
point and to other atheistic
existentialist that are coming after
starts that are sort of all of them old
disart
so it's it's it's obliged either to as
he said deny or to transcend itself he
thinks that the atheistic approach to
existentialism ultimately is going to
deny some aspects of the very themes
that it puts into play like the
contingency of existence came freedom
you know it's going to undo the
achievements that it's made or it has to
transcend itself it says it transcends
itself or tends to transcend itself when
it opens out it opens itself out to the
experience of the superhuman an
experience which can hardly be ours in a
genuine and lasting way this side of
death so you know what does Marcel
talking about there is he talking about
the explicitly Christian or in his case
Catholic faith not necessarily he's
saying we just have to be open to
something that is actually transcendent
to the purely human world and that
doesn't necessarily mean that it's going
to erupt into the world but we have to
remain open to that possibility
he's very showst Oviatt in that way if
we don't remain open to it we can never
actually verify whether it's there or
not if we rule it out from the beginning
or if we're open in sort of passive
aggressive not really open ways then
we're sort of prejudicing the entire
inquiry from the start
and Marcela's is saying look
existentialism has to go either this way
or this way this dividing line between
atheistic existentialism and you know
Christian and Jewish existential ISM or
even you know people like liquor ilka is
a massive gulf right there and people
like coming and started really thinking
out that where this is going and Marcel
wants to say this path is the one that
we ought to take ultimately or that we
simply can't rule it out so that that's
one thing that that's important that
he's bringing up the other thing that he
brings up and this is really a powerful
ladder for criticism against
art is that Sartre has managed to place
himself in a kind of dilemma Marcel is
talking about starts commitment to
atheism but I think this could apply to
all of the themes that are being
discussed here like the nature of the
social order whether it's you know
totally restrictive and something we
have to get away from in order to
experience our freedom and and or
whether you know being for self always
implies bad faith well they're playing a
role and always involves bad faith SAR
has a dilemma here's the dilemma as
Marcel articulates it either the
position that he's staking out is one
that actually has a universal sort of
validity to it that is it does apply to
- everybody is talking about human
beings as such in the way that you know
Enlightenment thinkers and pre
enlightenment thinkers in philosophy did
speaking about human nature in which
case it seems like Sartre is
contradicting himself because he says
man doesn't have a nature we create we
create our nature through our choices so
he's got a problem there and so start
really can't pick that side of the
dilemma on the other hand if he picks
the other side and his commitment to
atheism or to you know any of the other
things that we're talking about are
really the product of his own choice
then they cannot be made binding on
everybody else and yet Sartre seems to
think that they are binding he adopts
the attitude of the atheist who says
well yes I a thei ISM because it is
actually the right the right thing to do
and you're free to think whatever you
know
nonsense you want about Flying Spaghetti
Monster Zazi theists always like to
caricature things but you know it's
still nonsense but that presupposes
something like this over here that he's
already rejecting over here
so it starts in kind of a bind and
Marcel is pointing this out ultimately I
would say that Sartre has to fall on the
side of saying you know I I'm just
sketching out what I think actually is
most true but I'm thinking it's most
true from my position and it doesn't
have to be binding on everybody else all
those certs you know he does seem to
think that a lot of people are in bad
faith so those are all of the major
points that we're going to be going over
those are some of the things to keep in
mind now we actually want to look at
Marcel's discussion we're going to go
through this essay
bit by bit about the nature of existence
existentialism is going to be about in
part existence it's in the very name so
Marcel is very interested in sart's
conception of existence and he says that
there's an initial experience of
existence running through sorts works
and he's even willing to say I think
that this is I'm willing to grant that
this experience is genuine and then he
says a preamble of this must be an
account of this must be a preamble that
any kind of starts anthropology and he
says the taken in itself it seems
irrefutable now you've noticed I've got
the word nausea up here yeah that's the
title of a book but it's also the name
for a kind of experience of existence
raw existence that John Paul Sartre is
articulating in other places but
especially in that early novel of his
and if you haven't you know read it or
watch the video I suggested doing both
the video that I produced on that I've
got a two-part series on it
I would suggest I'm going through that
because that will help understand this
but you don't actually need to do that
in order to see what Marcel is saying he
says that nausea is a novel but it's in
no sense of work of fiction there can be
no doubt as to who the care
the hero really is real Quentin its art
himself and he has these these
experiences of what we could call the
radical contingency of being the being
of beings that had multiple times in the
novel and he's got some examples here
that I actually don't want to go over
because I want to save some time and he
says that what are you really core to
sart's experience of this this nausea
this this reaction to the existence of
things and also of one's self it's a
negative reaction he says seems to be
bound up in its origin with an
experience of fluency brings up this
firm fluency they says this is not the
same thing as fluidity the fluency is
when things that aren't really supposed
to be flowing mobile are doing so so for
example this piece of truck is hard and
it also is soft in a certain way that's
why I can write on the chalkboard with
it what if I were to experience this
chalk is kind of you know shifting in my
fingers and plausibly becoming other
than a cylindrical shape losing its
whiteness into some other colors or the
whiteness itself becoming kind of
oppressive that would be similar to what
what Sartre is describing and he says
what is what is fluent slows down and
assumes a kind of swamped love this
phrase soft yeah
spurious solidity so the things that we
take as being solid as sort of the the
landmarks in our environment really are
deceiving us or were sorta deceiving
ourselves about the fact that they they
aren't as solid as they appear to be he
brings up the term gooeyness and he says
gooeyness is indeed the key word but it
is for Sartre gooeyness on an enormous
scale like the entire environment or
unit
our field of perception becoming that
and he says for him the whole of life if
not actually GUI is at least tending
towards gooeyness what he has in mind is
a certain experience of secretions and
mucus in process of formation so I get
fluency
we've got greenness that often in
philosophy we get to talk but this for
this stuff and this not only applies to
objects outside of ourselves he says
that force art part of what's going on
is the experience of one's self as sort
of a mass of gooey secreting always
somewhat fluid types of things he's got
this great example here he says let's
say this is Marcel's words I apprehend
myself both as the secretion and as the
mucous membrane or rather as the mucous
membrane in process of secretion nothing
could be less formed less definite and
surely does this absence of contours
that the principle of nausea resides him
but further and more paradoxically the
same is true for instance of my hand
Yannick says for Sartre the human being
is in a certain way the prey of
existence existence is hunting us we are
not what we appeared to be and he's got
this great metaphor here you know in
Kafka's famous story the metamorphosis
this guy wakes up to find himself
transformed into a monstrous beetle were
actually a vermin depending on how you
want to translate the word some sort of
insect marcel says what if you were
transformed not into an ant with a whole
ant heap not just crawling with the ants
but yourself the seat the center of this
monstrous proliferation which literally
comes out of him and which on leaving
him still remains incomprehensibly
himself now if we take a you know
phenomenological attitude towards
ourselves that is one possibility for
how we can in fact view our experience
our bodies are relation to our
environments our Durance over time and
you know it's showing us sides of things
that we ordinarily don't see and they're
kind of unsavory could we escape this by
taking refuge in thought start says no
because thought itself is is he says the
most incipit of all it pulls out
endlessly and leaves a kind of
aftertaste then there are words inside
and unfinished words fragments of
sentences which come back again it's
worse than all the rest because I
actually feel responsible for it because
it's my thought but even thought doesn't
have these sharp solid contours like we
would like it to here and Marcel says
now notice something here note the role
of intermediary played by an image
between the actual experience of the act
of thinking and the nausea which is
associated with this act it's quite
impossible that my thought should appear
to be spontaneously or as a kind as a
kind of vicious band like a filament of
toffee or licorice for this to happen my
thought has to withdraw from itself and
to imagine itself as it would appear if
it were seen as an object so my thought
which is actually an active process has
to objectify itself metaphor eyes itself
image of Phi itself as some sort of
object which thought it actually is not
so something a little bit hinky is going
on here you might say on sart's part but
Marcel says look let's grant that and
let's go on what could be an opposition
to this well start sort of sketches out
this this frozen empty Street where
everything is what it is where
everything has a kind of rigidity and
solidity and contours and you can count
on everything and he says I want to be
like that I actually you know don't want
to be this humid materiality as Marcel
calls it and what is Marcel's diagnosis
of
so it's not like Sartre is the first
person to realize the contingency of
existence and existing things in my
relation to existing things many people
in the past have experienced this not in
terms of this nausea that start is
talking about but the overabundance of
being it's sort of generosity its its
goodness
so he says Sartre experiences that not
as overabundance of being but as
fundamental and absurd contingency
nature it nausea is at bottom the
experience of contingency and of the
absurdity which attaches to existence as
such and then he talks about the famous
you know root the chestnut tree root in
the park experience that the Sartre
details in the book and he says make no
mistake about it it's not really the
existence of the thing which is being
challenged one might say incriminated
but existence as such for an
existentialist art is actually kind of
anti existence and he says not the
comparison when Sartre is talking about
this that's meant to underline is loosed
unbuttoned excess what could be further
than this further than this from the
traditional vision of the overabundance
of being which haunted all the great
poets particularly the pantheist from
Lucretius to Maurice de garam the
overflowing richness of reality which
was experienced by them as something
positive a kind of glory is for Sartre a
looseness an obscenity and I think about
what obscenity means is if existence is
I've seen it is offending us in some way
with its flabbiness with its its help
ability it's also happening within us
too we are experiencing that of our
cells according to Sartre he says man
himself is a part of this Lewis and
Marcel calls this sart's
negative enlightenment says mark this
particular combination of words for it
is a clue too much of starts work it is
because starts and light
is negative that his philosophy is in
the last analysis of philosophy of
non-being and he says if there is any
light in things it can only come from
myself insofar as consciousness sort of
casts a light onto things and
illuminates them and what we've got here
then is the experience of not only
existence but being as something
fundamentally negative not in the sense
that it's not there or just not what it
what it is
but in the sense of being to as the
Sartre says to throw too much of what it
is and we experience that in ourselves
as part of what we are just as we do the
other things
in fact our particular human dignity is
in fact for Sartre a kind of abjectness
the coffee cup does not realize what it
is and how disgusting it is we human
beings can that's Marcel's read so far
on on Sartre in terms of this now we
need to turn to the next topic looking
at another set of passages in sart's
nausea the discussion of all these
portraits like the town fathers the
people who are notables Marcel says that
something that you can you can detect in
sart's work running throughout it is
this this what he calls a resentment
against all that is implied by social
order and perhaps my order is such so
Sartre is is resentfully takes a
negative attitude towards social order
why well because in many respects you
know social order is associated with
convention and its associated also with
power and these are sort of a lack of
freedom
and if we go along with them we're
choosing to be unfree we're choosing to
use our freedom to deny itself and so
Sartre is against the bourgeoisie not
just because he's you know tempted by
Marxism but because he thinks like a lot
of you know the French intellectuals did
and a lot of our bobo's do today you
know bourgeois Bohemians that you know
there it's an inauthentic existence it's
a kind of existence that to choose or to
go along with necessarily precludes one
from being able to to be authentic and
to live a rich full life and so here's
what Marcel says insert all middle-class
virtue is regarded as Ferris cycle and
he says indeed it may be he asked since
the publication of the wall that short
story and the paths of Liberty for the
passive freedom the first book of which
is the age of reason which I suggest
everyone should read all virtue conjugal
filial etc with the possible exception
of courage is not treated as middle
class and consequently as de classe and
valueless so there's there's also a
rejection of virtue virtue means you
know good character traits good things
that are in a person except courage and
I would suggest reading the short story
the wall to see this Illustrated because
it does provide a great example of that
he goes on and he says Sartre has a kind
of sympathy and also contempt for the
celibate so there's the there's the
celibate the person who does not engage
themselves in sexual relations there is
what we might call the you know the
bourgeois getting married courting doing
all these conventional things that
people do
producing children raising children
these are kind of opposed to each other
but then there's also a third term in
this and that would be the deliver teen
who says screw Convention I'm going to
you know enjoy pleasure as pleasure and
started is really on the other side of
that person but he just doesn't want any
to reduce everything to pleasure so he
says you can see the aversion that
Sartre feels for the paterfamilias
the father figure with us gaggle of
brats he says it should be noted that
for Sartre the very existence of the
family is profoundly suspect the family
is understood as being part of social
order but there's also you know to bring
up this term there so there's a
messiness a gooeyness a stickiness to
the family because you know you are
actually if any of you've ever had kids
you know that kids are just like a
constant mess Factory yeah you also once
you have kids you you find yourself a
bit overtaxed and things get a lot
messier around your place just because
you you let some things on your own
slide you you quit paying as much
attention to fastidiousness as you might
have in in earlier circumstances or in
other contexts yeah and so if there's if
there's going to be any sort of
situation in which Sartre is going to be
more ill at ease it's going to be there
but there's something more deep here
there's something metaphysical something
something ethical here marcel says sarch
world is really the world of the cafe or
the world has seen from the terrace of
the cafe and he says in addition to the
fact that the family must represent for
Sartre that vicious element which he
particularly dalat dislikes i believe
the father of a family must always
appear to him as someone who's just
playing a part to use a formula which is
not one of starts but which i think is
starting to be a father is to be always
and inevitably someone who acts the role
of a father
indeed if he did not act this role he
would be immediately accused of being an
unnatural parent so to to involve
oneself in in family life force art is
inevitably to allow oneself to lapse
into bad faith this this process of
thinking of oneself in terms of one's
role and trying to act according to that
role and Marsol seems to think that you
know with some roles that would be bad
if my if my role is just to be well you
know we can do this with fatherhood
there there are some people who are
clearly striving to be dad of the year
and to get the mug but they really
aren't good fathers in any real sense
they're not there they're there they're
lacking in what Marcel actually calls a
availability discipline to be late eh
they're not they're not there for their
children they they push them in this
direction in this direction they provide
for them but there's something lacking
there on the other hand to fulfill the
role of father really involves taking
yourself beyond just the role but the
role is in many respects the
precondition you know you do need to
actually show up to events that you're
not particularly interested because your
kid is going to that event and probably
drive them to that event and take them
back home from that event or at least
make some sort of effort to get there
and you may not feel like that's
authentic existence but that's the
precondition for a certain kind of
authentic existence qua father yeah I'm
you know Marsol here talks about
fatherhood he could be talking about
motherhood he could be talking about the
role of cousin or uncle he could be
talking about filial relations childhood
he could also be talking about the
entire world of dating and relationships
in all of these there is there's a
possibility of sort of playing a role
just as one might in
in an office or in any other place but
there's also the possibility of once one
is playing the role of going beyond that
because of the fabric of those those
relationships the nature of those
relationships and so by having such a
dim view on social order as is imposing
on a sort of a necessary lack of freedom
they have you know the cultivation of
any other virtues
besides courage is leading to a lack of
freedom Sartre
is in effect cutting himself off as a
good phenomenologist from an entire
range of experiences which he is then
not able to really take stock of so he's
kind of like putting on some blinders
some ideological and an effective
blinders this is what Marsellus is
criticizing at this point Marcel says
hey let's stop and examine this this
notion of playing a role we we want to
look at this this phenomenon a little
bit more carefully it says the performer
inevitably performs not only for others
but also for itself so playing a role
means playing a role or others and also
for one's self so you know to take
Fatherhood example for example I'm
trying to be a father to my children
they are some of the others I'm also
doing it for sort of an external
audience you know look at me I'm not a
bad dad I'm a good dad but I'm also
trying to do so for myself I'm trying to
you know project a self-image that I can
be ok with so he says therefore he's
acting rather than being playing a role
is really just acting it's being kind of
a hypocrite rather than actually being
what one purports to be so certainly
asked is this is this you know just a
perversion does it depend upon us to
avoid it as a stumbling block and he
says how is it possible to be he well as
it were being at the same time the
consciousness of one's own being
so that takes a little bit of explaining
there how is it possible to be something
well at the same time not being that
something but being the consciousness of
being that thing so if I am a day out I
am at the same time also the
consciousness of being dead which is not
the same thing as as being dead there's
this relationship between yeah itself
plain-old being we could say and then
being or itself and the human being can
straddles both of these consciousness is
really being for itself it is
consciousness of something but it is
also consciousness of itself as
conscious of something and we are the
creature that can take a stance of HA
ourselves which puts us to a certain
degree outside of ourselves so if I can
never be in the same way that this piece
of chalk is a piece of chalk and only a
piece of chalk anytime that I am
something for example as I'm a lecturer
shooting a video right now on youtube I
am at the same time not just that that
the fact that I am a lecturer shooting
on YouTube is a product of my own choice
to do so on some level I'm conscious of
that being the case and I'm kind of
acting in a certain way according to it
to start and you could say the same way
about people who are you know acting
like goofy people on YouTube and you
know comedians and it was like that so
he says if we want to get down to
principles what manner of being should
be attributed to a being who exists for
himself of being as conscious of his own
existence Sartre says being in itself is
completely full of itself it is purely
and simply what it is it has no
inwardness like we do consequently no
potentiality no future being for itself
does have potentiality does have a few
you can't understand what it's doing can
take a stance on that it can be in the
relationship of other two to other
things so he says that that the
characteristic of consciousness is it's
a decompression of being it's of the
essence of consciousness to be what it
is not and to not be what it is the
being of humanity of such it is able to
adopt a negative attitude in relation to
itself so this is a very important thing
to keep in mind for a for Sartre
and this is actually he's not the only
person to point this out but this is
this is something that's very important
in his work and perhaps the emphasis
upon it is is extraordinary that not
only are we able to be reflexive in the
sense of taking a position upon
ourselves we are able to take a negative
position we are able to say no or it's
not the chart can't do that the chart
can resist certain things but I can't
say no to them I can't even if it's
totally kick sonic I can say this is not
chalk I shall eat this there's a little
tiny sausage white sausage and chop it
down and I can make myself do that it's
silly to do so but it provides you with
an example here so for cert this
negative aspect is very important and so
there there's there's a lot of people
who take these these negative positions
he says suppose that I say to my son no
you are not to be an actor or I won't
let you be a dirt track racer I denied
to to his being these possibilities
which he planned for himself this is he
says what start means by Neil ation a
man sees a seal there even some people
guards overseers whose entire social
function is to be a no we might say in
song for some company's customer service
representatives right when you have a
scam set up their entire being is to say
no and he says there are other forms of
negation which are more
like in irony or Zonta month but these
are only possible because of this
Universal structure of being for itself
as negative which is alloyed with none
being why starts main work it's called
Being and Nothingness because at the
heart of being he says nothingness lies
coiled like a worm and we are tied up
with that nothingness with that that non
being so he says from Sartre standpoint
this is marcell presence is inferior to
coincidence because presence implies
separateness he says let's let's use a
sort of visual metaphor here imagine two
leaflets placed exactly on top of the
other this is coincidence now imagine
the leaflets have become slightly detach
this will correspond to less being as
compared with coincidence which was
perfect and as it were ideal this is no
longer being in itself we've got being
for itself if we ask ourselves what is
it that separates a subject from itself
we have we're obliged to say nothing
nothing plays a productive role in
certain sorts thought when this this
separation takes place it says in
general separation is created by
distance or the passage of time but
nothing separates for example the
consciousness of a belief from the
belief itself yet the fissure is there
the the separation is there it is intra
conscious but we'll come back to the
surface as bad okay so we come back to
the concept of being as impersonation as
playing role so he says to make this
clear here let's follow one of those
analyses of concrete examples in which
Sartre excels but from which he seems to
draw quite unwarranted conclusions so he
says this let's think of a woman who
goes out of date she knows that the guy
on the date wants to sleep with her she
manages to sort of keep that out of her
mind so that she can enjoy the date
because otherwise there's not going to
be any date and there's not going to be
any dinner and move
be and you know enjoying his charming
company and all that sort of stuff now
this is a very common experience you
know the the person who's kind very does
often doesn't want to see that the
connors is calming them the person is
seduced doesn't want to realize that
they're being seduced and they they hide
this from themselves and they play a
role of oh I didn't know that this was
going on and then of course the moment
comes where they have to decide in them
they can say oh I wasn't prepared for it
and that's exactly what start details
here he's talking about the the holding
her hand and he says she allows her hand
to be held it lies inert between his
warm hands neither consenting nor
resisting it is a thing she can see as
herself is not being her own body but is
seeing it from above it's a way of
treating oneself as having being in
itself as being this kind of thing and
treating other people that way as well
so bad faith consists in a certain act
of holding contrary notions which
combine an idea with its opposites and
he says the problem with this is that
each one of us has to make ourselves
what we are it's our manner of existence
they have to be what we are so we always
have to choose some sort of way in which
we're going to be and that's that's
bringing up the danger of playing a role
so he talks that about the waiter who's
playing at being a waiter and she says
you know it really starts examples got
some problems with them suppose I am
this waiter I shall have to say that I'm
trying to achieve the being in itself of
a waiter in a cafe as though indeed it
were not in my power to confer value an
urgency upon my rights and duties of
state as though I were not at liberty to
get up every morning at 5:00 or stay in
bed at the risk of Dean was being
dismissed as though by the very fact of
keeping up this role I were not
transcending it and as it were
establishing out the domain outside of
my condition as a waiter and he says
this cannot be true after the manner of
being in itself but only after the
manner of being that which I am
and this is true every one of my
attitudes so he says this requires some
elucidation go back a little is the
waiter a waiter by his essence in the
same way that he is for example a male
born under such and such conditions
evidently not he is a waiter in the
sense that he has to be a waiter he
earns his living by fulfilling this role
this is obviously true of many other
kinds of functions similarly it's
curious but for finally true that I
cannot say I am here I am NOT here in
the sense in which I say that this box
is or is not on this table we have a
different kind of being than mere
objects even when we are playing a role
we're not able to just be totally in bad
faith though a that start portrays
something like 99 for some of the people
out there is being he says here's where
starts analysis actually falls into
sophistry
yeah and started talking about emotions
at this point and says you know I make
myself sad and my soul says let me think
about this in a different way imagine
somebody dies a good friend of yours I'm
going to the funeral of an acquaintance
I'm sorry that he that he has died but
I'm not moved at all deeply as I come to
the house of mourning I'm affected by
sadness indeed I wish to some extent to
be affected by it so as not to be on the
tune of the bereaved family who I'm
coming to come to visit there there I
shall therefore not merely assume an
outward apartment I will make a real
effort to think of the event is
genuinely sad yeah that is in fact bad
faith right a lot of people do do that
you know think about relationships I'm
not really happy with this person but
I'm gonna I'm gonna will myself to to
feel in love with them and look on the
bright side people do that sort of thing
they also do the opposite oh this person
is no good for me you know no matter
what good good stuff they do and you
want to shake them and say what the
hell's wrong with you now he says all of
this is quite true but just because it's
true it's easy to see it's only part of
the truth this is the typical Marcel Yin
criticism of Sartre that starts getting
some
right but he's going too far with it
note that there's a form of experience
which at least superficially seems to
bear out starts view he says suppose I
am deeply grieved by the death of a
friend someone calls upon me who did not
know my friend and whom I do not wish to
confide it may be that I find in myself
the strength to control myself and to
appear to talk naturally about the
weather or about politics does this mean
that I have packed up my grief and
deposited like a parcel in the cloakroom
not at least merely playing a role does
not mean that the inward feelings go
away
I remain profoundly grieve sadness is
still in the depth of my consciousness
is something genuine and vivid which
underlies the attitude I have adopted
merely in order to conform to the social
code so he says there are other cases
where according to Sartre people refuse
to be with the arm for fear of being
confined to a form of being in itself
which would deprive them of their
freedom and once again Sartre is
engaging in a kind of analysis where
he's getting things partly right but
also getting them partly one and I'm
gonna skip over some of those examples
he says this is where we come to another
very dangerous equivocation where we're
mixing things up is not this
contradiction Sartre says precisely what
makes up the need for sincerity is not
the need for sincerity itself rooted in
bad faith Marcel says that's a kind of
inversion how do you actually make sense
out of the notion of bad faith what you
do so because of the contrast to
sincerity and it's only the sincerity
that is lacking that can actually allow
you to understand the meaning of bad
faith the sincerity doesn't actually
have to be present in order for that
this contrast to make sense but
sincerity must they actually be in order
for there to be bad faith
he says if sincerity itself is a
manifestation of bad faith then bad
faith cannot exist bad faith
can happy to find it cannot assume it's
specific character except by opposition
to sincerity he says here's another more
serious point Sartre claims that the
admission that we have this or that
characteristic that we're greedy or
deceitful is a manner of ridding
ourselves of that characteristic itself
if I admit that I'm a liar I shall be a
liar a little bit less by the very fact
of saying it I shall cease to be a liar
to the same extent and Marcel says
that's true some things well well
sorry's leaving out he says what Sartre
leaves out of account is the extremely
important fact that when a man who is in
good faith admits that he is flawed a
liar for example all he does is lay down
the conditions which in his estimation
might enable him to transform himself
that's completely lacking from starts
point of view to transform one's self
would just be to play another role to
fall into another set of conventions to
choose to make oneself another being in
itself and yet this doesn't actually map
on to our experience of feelings about
how screwed up we are and wanting to get
ourselves less screwed up and the
efforts that are required to do that
which involve actually admitting to
oneself how screwed up and in what way
is one is screwed up so he says that
what Sartre does not see is that
sincerity should not be regarded as a
virtue for its own sake it's a virtue
only as a necessary condition of a
certain inward effort at self mastery
shall we say at transcendence sincerity
is only really good for this effort of
transforming one's self of conforming
oneself to something that is greater
than oneself so he says I mean that when
I admit that I have this or that defect
I placed myself in a new position in
which the overcoming of that defect may
perhaps be possible
so again we've got something that has
been left out of the picture by start
this this capacity for ourselves to be
more than just our roles and to not
merely reduce ourselves to being in
itself and to not do those so solely
through negation through emulation as
Sartre will say there's a lot of knots
here you could say that it's almost like
a double negation going on one very
important part of sart's philosophy and
really indeed anybody's philosophy
that's going to to be more than just a
sort of abstract playing around with
things he has to do with what in
philosophy we call all Terry and that
means what we make of others yeah and
Marcel is gonna say the experience of
others if force art is the experience of
someone else and this sounds kind of
trivial but it's well worth reflecting
on he talks about this example that
started he has of you know walking
somewhere and seeing a person and to see
a person is not just to see you know
their shape in their body because it
could be a mannequin it could be you
know pop up targets or something like
that and you know for example you know
when I was in the military we would go
on these ranges and we don't actually
pop up targets and they pop up and you
shoot at them and you would only do that
because you had you know you think
that's not a person I'm training to
actually shoot people in wartime but
that's not a person because if it is I'm
sure as hell not gonna you know send
lead downrange at it and every once in a
while there would be a problem with you
know one of the one of the squads going
over in some other squads territory and
they would be perceived as pop-up
targets and then they would get shot at
and sometimes people would get injured
and kill yeah you know the person who's
back there you know thinking that
they're a pop-up target which is very
easy to you know occur when you're
hundreds of yards away and it's hard to
see they're not perceiving them as a
person they're perceiving them as just
an object
human beings are perceived or
experienced as
object and something more something else
and so mark saw is this example the same
sort of thing you know you if you're a
madman part of the pride you're saying
you see somebody out there and you're
like I'm gonna shoot that target part of
what's wrong is you're not perceiving
other human beings as human beings but
merely as objects so he says as soon as
I realize that this this object is is
not just a moving object it's a man I'm
not gonna shoot it so what happens that
that's where it gets really interesting
for certain the experience of others is
the experience of another self another
person and it force art it's inevitably
an experience of them as a rival correct
and it doesn't have to be this way
but this is something that runs through
sart's works very consistently smart
talks about the other person as being
kind of like a sinkhole of being if I
have this entire penumbra of
consciousness around me that I sort of
affect the world with I sort of extrude
into the world so does that person over
there but their meanings are not my
meanings their arrival to me for how the
world is being construed Marcel is this
brilliant metaphor that he came up with
himself saying each of us uses his
consciousness like a kind of a dragnet
in which as it were to catch everything
he sees consequently that other over
there using his dragnet to pull the
statue and the lawn to himself isn't a
certain sense my adversary and rival so
Marcel says sart's analysis is actually
masterly the relationship which might be
termed being seen by another is a fact
which cannot be deduced from the essence
either of myself as subject where the
other as object and this is what Sartre
call
the experience of the games the gaze of
it to be another for another that is
part of what it means to be a human self
so he says there's nothing more
remarkable in the whole of starts work
than his phenomenological study of the
other and looking and as himself as
exposed pierced Baird Bard petrified by
his medusa-like stare my subjective
reactions to this form of aggression are
in the first place fear the sense of
being endangered by the liberty of
another secondly pride or shame the
sense of being at last what I am but at
a distance for myself for another who's
over there and he says you know not
going to take too much space to discuss
this but he talks about the experience
of like you know looking through a
keyhole
you know we don't look through keyholes
very much but think of the experience of
watching something unsavory on your
laptop on the computer and it's all ok
until somebody else comes into the room
and then you know suddenly you feel very
different
that's what start is getting at with
this analysis of the keyhole you're
caught within the gaze of the other you
know if it's porn what a pervert you are
if it's political things and you know
the other person is of the different
political party you're one of those
people a objective ization of the self
is taking place through the gaze of the
other towards herself that is construing
us as a certain kind of object it's
forcing us into a certain kind of role
so he says it's not by chance that this
example has been chosen by Sark and its
species is speciousness is evident
eavesdropping is not an activity
ordinarily pursued in public if I
indulge in it I expect to be alone there
are other ways in which we
are with others where we're not caught
up in the gays the objectifying gays in
the same way Marcel says clearly for
Sartre the awareness of others is
inseparable from the shock of the
encounter with what he describes as a
freedom and alien freedom which is
adverse and threatening to himself and
the question that we could ask here is
why is the freedom of the other
necessarily threatening to us is that an
intrinsic part of our human being that
we can generalize to everybody we're
gonna start perhaps drawing too much to
idiosyncratically on his own experience
or the experience of his particular
class that he belongs to the epoch the
era that's what Marcel wants to suggest
to us so he says to be seen as to be at
the mercy of a freedom which is not my
own the sense of shame is bound with the
sense of falling into the world
then I'm dispossessed by the gaze of the
other and he says we're now here at the
root of the diabolical argument that's
developed in know no exit diabolical is
kind of a a pun there because because no
exit takes place in Hell right he says I
was recently told of an ingenious
comment by a manufacturer from the north
who after seeing the play in Paris said
to his confessor you told me sir twas an
atheist but he believes in the doctrine
of hell and the good man was quite
comforted and then Marcel says yeah but
you know this is not the hell of mom and
dad you know and the church and all that
this is a very earthly hell it's
actually a drawing-room all right and he
talks about this analysis by it by this
critic Campbell and Campbell says that
Sartre has achieved a hell of situation
by depriving the mind of those avenues
of escape which are ordinarily at its
disposal putting together a weakling a
demon iock and a woman of no importance
he has constituted a trio which is bound
to function as badly as possible and
Marcel's gonna kind of follow along with
us and say you know you can't actually
draw from no exit
a universal conclusion that hell is
other people you can draw the conclusion
that hell is other people for this kind
of person
so Campbell goes on and any notes that
you know the inability it's more
difficult to tell a lie before a third
party and each of these ends up being
the torture for the other and and he
says quoting BM start is weakened is
case by making an unnecessary concession
to the audience how so well one of the
characters is a deserter so he lacks
courage
another one is a lesbian at a time when
lesbianism you know seen as very deviant
behavior right the third one he actually
is an infanticide and so that's not
going to work either and and he says mr.
Campbell believes her hell would have
been no less hellish if Garson had been
a victorious general Estela virtuous
wife and mother and an as a Carmelite
Marcel says no the play would have
turned out very differently in that case
he says Sartre who was a very extremely
intelligent he's an extremely
intelligent writer saw his play would be
difficult to construct with
irreproachable characters however this
may be the play bears out what we've
already observed in connection with
being seen the tendentious missus art's
reasoning which in the end becomes so
marked we're forced to ask ourselves
what lies at the root of the prejudice
which infects the whole of his work
which is we're coming to he says what is
in fact sart's approach to the theory of
awareness of others this is a very
important point this is a critical point
where Sartre seems to be providing us
with sort of irrefutable conclusions but
really he's beginning he's giving us his
premises which we should say I don't see
that those are actually proven he says
it's whole tendency is to assert that
human communication is doomed to failure
that the sense of community the sense of
forming part of a we subject is only
experienced on such occasions as when a
regiment is marching in step or a gang
of workmen is coming together so Sartre
is it
excluding the possibility no genuine
community so we ought to be very
suspicious at this point why is it that
no genuine community is possible well
because whenever you have community it's
just like you know people are marching
in lockstep and you know what we call
emotional contagion the the false
community of the ideological II whipped
up mob or the community that's available
through DNA siak sort of experiences
like you know the dancefloor and rave or
you know the mosh pits you know when
when the park or the metal bands are
playing and where the bouncers aren't
actually paying attention so you can use
violence as you want these experiences
where we kind of lose ourselves but then
we're losing ourselves it's not a we
really anymore it's just a kind of who
knows what they were caught up in well
that's not all there is to the
experience of community at home
that's it if so you're a very lonely
person if that's the only access to
being with another person that you
actually have where you're not merely
trying to objectify them or act as
rivals the fact that even if you haven't
experienced that the fact that others
have experienced it and written about it
should make you suspicious of sart's
intransigence on this point so he says
you know when it comes to the genuine
community the community of love or a
friendship this arts analysis of love
and being and nothingness and still more
the illustrations of that analysis and
the age of reason the age of reason is a
novel that perfectly illustrates sart's
philosophical position played out reveal
the fundamental egg and Gnosticism
needed neol ism of his view starts
analysis of love as Marcel is conducted
in such a way that it's bound to arrive
and a wholly negative conception the aim
of love is to appropriate the will of
the other so our attitude towards others
has to be antagonistic I want to
appropriate the will of the other why
not to simply a power over them but in
order to acquire absolute value in the
eyes of the beloved thus to transform
the alien gaze which had previously
passed through me or immobilized me into
an in itself that is I turn the other
into a thing which is going to reflect
upon me as being good beautiful pick
whatever you know transcendent value
that you like thereby neutralizing them
they say well what do they don't feel
like projecting that gaze to me well
then I'm going to be stuck in this
antagonistic situation once again so he
says the ingham of globe force art is to
cease being seen as ugly or small or
cowardly instead of feeling that my
existence is superfluous I would feel
that it is upheld and willed even in its
smallest details by an absolute will and
absolute freedom which is itself
conditioned by my own existence and
willed by my own freedom the essence of
the joy of love insofar as it exists is
to feel that my existence is justified
so really what love is for start is this
ravenous desire to be affirmed by the
other love is not affirmation of the
other love is not self donation to the
other love is not even having something
in common in terms of friendship or
affection that has come up over time and
it's not even desired just to you know
have sex with the other two you know
force them to be right here so I can
look at them and gaze upon them love is
the desire for the desire of the other
Sartre says so what can we say about
this like Mark Marcel says well that's
unattainable and since CERN has said
that's all that love can be or
friendship or respect that's on the
table as well
so we're condemned to a universe which
ultimately is going to disappear
he says search shows to what perversions
to what extremes the sadism or masochism
blob can give rise to he's good and for
that sort of thing when it does not sink
and do indifference or degenerate into
hate but that's not all there is to the
story and he says it's clear that the
the premise that this resides on is this
denial of the possibility of genuine
community the complete denial of we is
subject that is to say the denial of
communion for Sartre Marcel says this
word has no meaning at any possible
level not to speak of its religious or
mystical sense that is because in his
universe participation itself is
impossible participation is impossible
this is the essential point there is
room only for appropriation and so
there's a very big difference between
participation where there has to be sort
of a back-and-forth of reciprocity or
even a recognition of transcendence
something that I need to actually
involve myself in and conform myself to
instead for Sartre there's only the
possibility of appropriation everything
must be placed on my level or below and
I take from it I don't give to it I take
from it and that is going to do the same
thing to me too if I'm not careful as a
matter of fact it may have been doing
them all the way so this is going to be
a very dim view of love communion of
friendship but this is where starts
philosophy he has to go because of the
way in which he's set it up that's
Marcel's diagnosis we come now to one of
sart's most essential there's a pond
their points namely that man is
condemned to be free and that's freedom
is of the very essence of human beings
but that's what deprives us of having an
essence so we must determine our essence
and Marcel wants to examine this this
conception of Sartre and freedom because
he thinks there there's some things off
with it and so he says let's look look
at this this freedom of which Sartre
constantly speaks and he asked ourselves
in which it in what it consists so
what is this freedom he says the
definitions that start gives a rather
obscure we must not be put off by such
formula such as freedom as man's faculty
to secrete ozone non-being or that is
man's capacity to be the foundation of
himself what is freedom for served he
says well it's going to have to do with
choice it's not just going to be choice
though because it has to do with this
capacity to say no which in English gets
translated mean donation in French
Nancy's ass y'all literally a nothing is
nothing you know to to nothing something
so he says it's the idea that by virtue
of being human I have the power to
withdraw to break with all this
factitious world but in so doing so I
become this break itself I had nothing
but this beyond this transcendence he's
talking about that this character who's
you know debating about whether to kill
himself and then he goes through this
discussion he says the words I am
condemned to freedom should be
underlined
what would they actually have sounded
like we're song uses to somebody like
Descartes or man to be round very
important French philosopher for the
french-speaking world not very well
known here in english-speaking countries
or to any genuine philosopher of the
past so they said well what can I
actually be condemned surely it must be
to a loss to a deprivation whether of
life of wealth of Honor or freedom I
cannot be condemned to freedom unless
freedom is kind of a bad thing
unless freedom is a deprivation of loss
and for Sartre freedom indeed is like
consciousness of deprivation of defect
it is only by a kind of parallelism that
he later represents us as a positive
condition of the emergence of the world
and thus bestows upon it a creative
value there's a bipolarity inside its
treatment of freedom so he goes yes
how is it that we actually make
decisions possible how do we cross over
from in determination from defect a
decision properly so called
and he says no first of all there's no
question of start following the
philosophical tradition which places
freedom in the act of deciding sorry
says freedom coincides at its roots with
the non-being which is at the heart of
man for human being to be is to choose
himself nothing comes from him either
from without or from with himself from
within himself that he can receive or
accept and Marcel has this parenthetical
remark this is note that that passage
and let me go back over it again nothing
comes to him from either either from
without or from within himself that he
can receive or accept he must make
himself be he must choose he must choose
what he's going to be but he cannot take
this from anywhere else so Marcel says
this seems actually to be one of the
most significant and explicit passages
and all the starts work why he says I
don't believe that in the whole history
of human thought grace even its most
secularized form has ever been to nine
with such audacity or such impudence
freedom is is equivalent to choice and
then he goes through and Marcel lays out
some some propositions and you know
self-determination is of our essence the
nature of an act is defined by its
intention its intention goes beyond the
given actuality the end reveals the
nature of the world the world reveals
itself for what it is it is in
accordance with the nature the chosen
end and he's sort of summarizing sart's
views here but he says I'm going to
criticize the most important points to
begin with I'm inclined to think that as
on so many occasions starts mate cert
makes an exaggerated use of the concept
of negation so this is no this this
minyul asian this withdrawal this
holding oneself back
from the things a refusal he says let's
take any of his examples see that a man
it feels that his family life has to
title hold on him that he's been
constant and spoiled seeks to disengage
himself from his family but a common
experience with college students for
example this is not the same thing as
saying that he denies his family it may
simply mean he's trying to establish a
free relationship in place of what had
been a stranglehold this is this simple
example taken from everyday life shows
how unsuitable and even dishonest is the
use of the term Nanta zasio you know the
saying no the Malaysian with its
deliberately negative associations but
there's still something more serious and
he says can it be legitimate to say that
for the human being being is equivalent
to doing is this not something more than
a simplification are we really only what
we make ourselves to be let me say that
one more time are we only what we make
ourselves to be is our essence is who we
are
only what we've chosen for ourselves or
does receptivity play a role Sartre is
is according to Marcel ruling miss out
anytime that I received something on
this ontological level from someone else
about myself and said yes that is that
is part of who I am that is what I am I
am in bad faith I am choosing to not
negate that and to accept that
yeah and that can only be that thing
turning me into a kind of object through
my own turning myself into an object so
if I embrace my American myths for
example I'm to be in bad faith according
to Sartre and yet there are some very
important things
come to me about my being that I might
want to actually accept hold on to
celebrate explore and start is ruling
that out Marcel says for start to
receive is incompatible with being free
indeed a being who is free is bound to
deny to himself that he has received
anything and he says I wondered here if
the author of nausea does not fall into
one of the worst errors which can be
attributed to idealism in this case as
soon as the one who receives as
conceived as a recipient the true
character of receptivity is ignored as
soon as receptivity in a spiritual or
even a living being is confused with
suffering in a material sense having
something forced upon you if that's all
that recept if 'ti means then then of
course it can't be anything good it
can't be something that augments one's
freedom or makes one's freedom possible
he says there remain only two terms of
reference an actuality which is so to
speak inert and a freedom which denies
that only to assume it in an
incomprehensible way at a later stage so
what is going on here he says here's
what Sartre actually says Sartre says
man is a useless passion he Dana aspires
to achieve in his own person that
impossible synthesis would which would
result in being in itself man's life is
an attempt continually renewed and
inevitably doomed to failure at the
divinization of himself and why would
man have to divin eyes humanity or the
human person have to Gemini's themselves
well because they can't accept anything
from anywhere else and it's in a certain
way to be cause of Sooey
one's own cause is in fact one of the
prerogatives of divinity traditionally
spoken spoken of right the uncaused
cause freedom for Sartre has to be
negative and has to turn against things
and cannot accept receptivity there's a
little strangeness and saying that right
it simply cannot construe receptivity as
anything other than somebody imposing
something on me or me being sucker
enough to impose it upon myself is this
an adequate conception of freedom Marcel
thinks no Marcel thinks that this
reflects a fundamental confusion at the
heart of sart's very metaphysics and
where is it coming from he says well
it's actually coming from a sort of
atheism that is postulated says we're
here in the contrary in the presence of
explicit and and aggressive atheism and
here's where he he poses that that
dilemma for Sartre he says should we not
ask what is the pattern of the origin of
starts atheism either he must admit that
his atheism derives from an attitude of
the will that is from a choice from
freedom or from an initial resentment
that would be the case of a man who from
the very depth of his being willed that
God should not exist again freedom
spontaneity such an answer would be in
keeping with his doctrine that would be
actually consistent for with what he's
saying but it would destroy much of its
metaphysical bearing because then Sartre
would not be able to say yeah atheism is
right not only for me but for everybody
else you'd only be able to say I'm
willing it to be right for me and
thereby for everybody else but that guy
over there who may make a totally
different use of his freedom and since
the universe doesn't really depend in
what it is on either one of our freedom
it could very well be that God exists
and that guy's freedom is actually more
aligned with what's going on Sartre
doesn't want to say that so the other
terminally the dilemma he must take a
stand on the traditional ground of
objective thought and declare that there
is no God as one might say that there
are no people on Mars but in that case
you must give up the plane of
existentialism and fall back on the most
obsolete positions of traditional
rationalism so start is in a bind there
and he says this metaphysical proud of
the problem raised by
philosophy is not that what I'm trying
to deal with here the essential question
of my mind is whether this philosophy is
not heading for the abyss into which the
forces of self-destruction threatened to
drive our unfortunate race he says I
actually am convinced that that's what's
going on yeah I think that start is
involved with what he calls the
techniques of vilification and what does
it mean to vilify something we usually
think of it as just a criticize to the
to parade he says I mean techniques
which result deliberately or not in the
systematic vilification of man what does
it to vilify saz etymologically it's to
take away its value its price so to
vilify freedom to take away its value
and he says somebody might have jacked
and say wait a second Sartre is all
about freedom I mean how can you say
that start is vilifying freedom when
that's one of the central points of his
philosophy and marcel points out two
things he says it must not be forgotten
that the fascist dictatorships
similarly exalted the people and offered
it a ceaseless and cheap adulation yet
what contempt did not this an elation
concealed and what object depth did they
not reduce their citizens to I fear that
the relationship between starting his
disciples and between them and the
humanity they claimed to exalt may
follow an analogous pattern so that
there's really a deep contempt for human
beings contaminating this yakin temper
for freedom even though it's exalting it
to the skies it's not saying starts a
fascist by the way users using that as
an example the other example that he
uses is he says another way to vilify if
you want to reduce the value of
something flood the market
he says you can do this in the case of
merchandise by flooding the market this
is just what Sartre does to freedom he
bases it by putting it in in every stall
he says Sartre would of course
indignantly protest against the
suggestion that in his philosophy
freedom is easy but if we're condemned
to be free freedom actually is easy no
matter what I do is freedom it's read
them over here it's read them over there
I'm constantly engaging in my freedom if
I choose not to use my freedom that's
also freedom and after a while freedom
kind of loses its meaning doesn't it
when you when you do that that's what he
was calling the vilification of freedom
so he says you know if we actually look
at the way Sartre behaves you know and I
says this raises the whole question of
values as they're conceived of by Sartre
he's got a problem from his standpoint
values can't be anything but the result
of the initial choice made by each human
being in other words they can never be
recognized or discovered again we see
this problem with receptivity values
can't possibly impose themselves upon us
as something to which we want to have as
other phenomenologist would say a proper
value response the value of the
transcendent the value of life the value
of the beautiful the value of the noble
only we can give value to these values
through our choice
Sartre would say my freedom is the
unique foundation of values and since I
am the being by virtue of which values
exist nothing absolutely nothing can
justify me in adopting this or that
value or scale of values my freedom is
an anguish of finding it is the baseless
basis of values that's what Sartre says
and Marcel says nothing could be more
explicit the question is whether Sartre
does not actually go counter to the
Exxon's exigencies of that human reality
which he claims after all not to invent
but to reveal and he's going to close
this essay by looking at some of sart's
own commitments and own writings and the
values that Sarge claims
to espouse and exemplify and articulate
in those so you know for example the
paths of Liberty that I mean paths of
freedom the first of which is the age of
reason Sartre announces that in the
third volume is going to be devoted that
praise the heroes of the wrists
resistance and then Marcel says that's
all fighting good
I like the resistance guys but Sartre in
the name of what principle and having
first denied the existence of values or
at least of their objective basis can
you establish any appreciable difference
between those uh Turley misguided but
undoubtedly courageous men who joined
voluntarily the anti-bolshevik legion
who actually fought as you know for the
for the Nazis and the heroes of the
resistance movement I see no way of
establishing this difference without
admitting that causes have their
intrinsic values and consequently that
values are real sart's philosophy says
that they're not so how is Sartre
himself going to adopt values and say
that these people actually took on the
right values these people took on the
right values collaborators were wrong
resistance were right it seems precluded
by starts own philosophy so he says the
truth is this is Marcel speaking and
sort of articulating his own viewpoint
on this if I examine myself honestly
without reference to any preconceived
body of ideas I find I don't actually
choose my values I recognize them and
then posit my actions in accordance or
in contradiction with these values not
however without being painfully aware of
this contradiction again we see this
importance of receptivity that there are
things outside of ourself that that
there is meaning available to us and
it's up to us whether we not just accept
it as purely passive but whether we take
it on and and embrace it or criticize it
or modify it how we take it on play is
it important
all this receptivity that is integral to
the human condition so this is where he
leads to the the very last part that
where he says existentialism stands at a
parting of the ways this is where we
began this discussion this is where
we're going to end it it is in the last
analysis obliged either to deny or to
transcend itself Marcel is saying sart's
version of existentialism ultimately
becomes incoherent
so if existentialism really is going to
be a going concern it's going to have to
transcend itself it cannot be a complete
philosophical position let alone one
that would sort of rule all the others
out as being in bad faith or you know
ignoring the concrete exigencies of our
existence or any of those sorts of
things
it would have to open itself up to
something which is greater and that may
be very different things for different
existentialist so you know for the for a
Catholic like Marcel this may be the
mysteries of the Catholic Church and
what they have to teach us for Martin
Buber it could be you know his Jewish
faith for Rilke it may be what it is
that things actually have to teach us
because things are not merely objects
the way that Sartre thinks they are and
through them and through nature and
through our solitude we can we can find
our way back to to God these are all
different possibilities of transcending
existentialism from within the
existentialist perspective so Marcel is
saying look you can't just like hold it
here as this frozen thing you're either
gonna go down are you going to go up so
pick which way you're gonna go actually
use your power to choose and don't just
pick the negative path that's the sort
of ultimate takeaway message I think
from this this wonderful critique this
critical analysis that's very intensive
to what's right and starts philosophy
but equally attentive to what is
misguided and what is tendentious in
sart's philosophy